good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it's weird to say it but
this is the last day
of the trump administration if you
supported donald trump that's a sad
thing to face
after four years on the other hand if
you didn't support
donald trump if you're one of the many
in our professional class who have made
hating donald trump the very center of
your life
this has got to be a pretty good day for
you you won
your party now has control of everything
by tomorrow afternoon donald trump will
be gone for good
you got exactly what you wanted you
should be thrilled about that you ought
to be celebrating
but they're not celebrating that's the
remarkable thing no one in the
democratic party seems happy tonight
they're angrier than ever instead of
taking victory laps they are plotting
revenge against the people they just
beat
they're thinking of new ways to injure
and humiliate and degrade their
political opponents
make it impossible them for them to work
again throw them in jail
destroy their lives it's hard to
describe how
weird and strange and awful this is to
watch
imagine winning a tennis match in
straight sets then immediately
leaping over the net and smashing your
opponent in the face with your racket
it wasn't enough for you to win you had
to inflict physical
pain you couldn't be happy until another
human being
screamed in agony what kind of person
would do that
well the kind of people are watching now
the kind of people who are even more
vicious
when they win the leaders of the
democratic party have now decided that
74 million trump voters weren't just
wrong or misguided
they didn't simply back the wrong guy or
have incorrect opinions or fail to see
the obvious truths
no the threat they pose is graver and
more serious than that more dangerous
these 74 million trump voters are in
fact
terrorists they're a looming physical
threat to the rest of us and we must
deal with them
in the way that you deal with threats
like that existential threats
to the nation saddam hussein al-baghdadi
kim jong-un
donald trump's voters for years they
told us this country had been
infiltrated by russian spies but now we
know it's worse than that
the real threat the actual enemy is
within
in the end it always is 74 million
deviationists lurk in our midst they
look like normal people
but ladies and gentlemen do not be
deceived they are trotskyites
they're wreckers cool acts we must root
them out it'll take a war
to do that an actual war a war on our
own people
to make that point as clear as possible
the democratic party has marshaled
military leaders to deliver the news
they're the party's spokesman now
general stanley mcchrystal is among them
but crystal in case you don't remember
is the strategic genius who can take
credit if you can call it that
for running the longest losing war in
american history the one in afghanistan
the war that's still going
yesterday mcchrystal took a break from
collecting fat corporate director's fees
to note that
based on his extensive experience
mismanaging america's foreign policy
trump voters look an awful lot like
terrorists an awful lot
quote i did see a similar dynamic in the
evolution of
al qaeda in iraq mcchrystal said
where a whole generation of angry arab
youth with very poor prospects
followed a powerful leader who promised
to take them back to a time to a better
place
and he led them to embrace an ideology
that justified their violence
this is now happening in america
al qaeda in america thanks stan
sometime when you can manage to spare a
moment from getting rich from your
failures in america's decline
we'd love to know exactly what did
happen in afghanistan what went wrong
there
when you have time until then though
andy mccabe would like to put a finer
point on the matter you remember andy
mccabe
he's the former high-level fbi official
who was canned for lying and corruption
a model federal employee so when andy
mccabe speaks you could hear the moral
authority in his voice
gravely and resonant like cigarette
smoke you're going to want to listen
carefully to what andy mccabe has to say
according to annie mccabe's considered
judgment donald trump's voters
are very much like isis listen to this
when we looked at those americans who
traveled to syria for the purpose of
joining the islamic state
when you put all those faces and names
down in one place
you had doctors lawyers some people are
very vulnerable to
and drawn into that that core lie
of any extremist movement and that is
exactly what we're seeing now with
these this particular group of trump
supporters
wait american national security official
andy mccabe
is telling us they're like isis islamic
state in syria
aren't those the wild-eyed lunatics who
beheaded journalists and set all those
people on fire and then
videotape themselves doing it wow
that's terrifying that's right mr mrs
america
what we didn't tell you before was that
isis
was for donald trump that's why they
were murdering so many people they were
the syrian branch of magga
you may have heard it was some kind of
islamic thing come on that's racist
it was donald trump all along now those
people are in this
country in dallas and sarasota and
newport beach
everywhere they're hiding in plain sight
god knows what they will do next
actually we do know another 911 that's
what they're planning
and that's why we need a new 911
commission to root them out
but thankfully commander pelosi is
planning one right now
watch there is strong interest in the
congress
in the 911 type commission a deep look
in a 911 style
commission to really get to all of what
happened yeah they need a 911 type
commission of inquiry
along the lines of a 911 commission a
911 type commission
and hopefully an independent 911 style
commission
will look at i think this is a big
enough threat an attack
on the center of our democracy that it's
going to need a look that spans
branches of government something closer
to a 911 commission
well i think we know they're on the same
email chain but that doesn't change the
substance of what they just told you did
you hear
jim comey and other noted moral
authority what jim let me told you is
that what happened in washington on
january 6th
the chewbacca guy stumbling around the
house floor and all of it
that was this generation's 911
and in fact the magnitude of that
atrocity
begs for a better name so from now on
we're going to call it 1-6
and that day will live in infamy for all
time your grandchildren will get the day
off from school
every january 6th in remembrance of the
horror that took place
in fact here's a better idea let's call
it insurrection day
because honestly that's what it was
the president incited an insurrection
against congress to prevent the peaceful
transition of power
and then he sat back and watched the
insurrection
insurrection a violent mob
a white supremacist president who
incited a white supremacist insurrection
an insurrection against our government
the violent attack
on the u.s capitol was an act of
insurrection
the insurrection that violated the
sanctity of the people's capital
this was not a protest this was an
insurrection
bruce willis in insurrection day
but it's not a joke according to the
honorable jim mcgovern and everyone else
you just saw on the screen this was not
a protest how dare you call it that this
was an
insurrection insurrection insurrection
insurrection
write that 100 times on the board and
don't forget it i-n-s-u-r-r-e-c-t-i-o-n
insurrection learn it
love it but you should also know by the
way for frame of reference what an
insurrection is not for example
yesterday
28 people arrested at a violent protest
in new york
not on behalf of donald trump those
people attacked police officers
a bunch of them went to jail but know
this were they insurrecting at the time
no they weren't how do we know they
weren't because they weren't racists
only racists can insurrect listen
carefully to congresswoman ayanna
presley explain
the threat of white supremacy looms
large
and it is uh tragic that it took this
insurrection
and this attempt to interrupt the
peaceful transfer of power and moreover
uh injury and loss of life for many to
appreciate
just how formidable the threat of white
supremacy is
well this is a tough one so what do you
do with insurrectionists like that
insurrectionists who were also white
supremacists as they always are but not
and here's the tricky part
in some cases even white so you have
non-white
white supremacists who insure that's
very tough
how do you handle them simple force
doesn't always work these are hard cases
you need to re-educate people like that
possibly
in camps re-education camps if you will
you must
de-program them for the safety of the
rest of us
thankfully sandy cortez has been
thinking about this for quite some time
indeed
since she was a child growing up in
leafy westchester county
some little girls played with dolls but
sandy cortez put her barbies in a secure
enclosure and re-educated them
because they were thinking bad things
forbidden things so sandy cortez knows
exactly what to do now
we had a program addressing white
supremacists
that we had programs federal programs
um that went towards funding
organizations like these
that de-radicalized people and
president trump pulled the plug on
federal funding for some of these
programs and so
one thing that we know is that we have
to get that funding right back up and we
probably need to
double triple quadruple um or increase
funding for these de-radicalization
programs
bad barbie bad barbie bad barbie those
are naughty thoughts
this federal program will deprogram you
so you listen to that and all of this
and you realize the totalitarian
instinct is
always the same always only the names
the dictators change
first you strip people of their right to
speak out loud honestly
then you prevent them from defending
themselves and their families
and then because you now can you force
them at gunpoint to read your catechism
to accept your
orthodoxy you wonder if sandy cortez
plans to make trump voters sign written
statements affirming they have been
deprogrammed
of course that's always part of the
process the scary thing is that's where
we're heading
sandy cortez and her friends are no
longer a fringe element within the
democratic party
joe biden ran as a moderate people voted
for him because they thought he was
but joe biden's victory was really a
victory for sandy cortez
and that part of the democratic party
they're closer now than they've ever
been to taking control
the reason for that is very simple there
is a massive
power vacuum at the center of this
incoming administration the one that
takes power tomorrow
joe biden is fading that is not a
personal attack on joe biden it is real
joe biden is not capable of running the
government or of pushing back against
the radicals in his party
the people around joe biden know this
very well and that includes people
very close to him including his
relatives people who love joe biden were
upset when he ran for president
they know he can't do the job and they
are very worried about what happens next
that is not speculation they have said
so out loud
and no honest person in joe biden's
orbit will deny this
so the question is who will fill the
power vacuum within the biden
administration
there are still and we're being as
honest as we can be there are still
reasonable people within the democratic
party there are people who have a stake
in this country people who don't want to
destroy it
and now is the time for those people the
reasonable people in the democratic
party
to step up forcefully and call off the
war
their party is planning on millions of
fellow americans
and it is war they're planning a 911
commission blanket censorship
mass arrests deprogramming these are not
subtle indicators these are fire alarms
and
everyone can see them no one seems to
care at the moment
in the last week cnn and the washington
post have called for fox news to be shut
down by force
why because they don't like our views so
we should be banned
in a normal country reasonable people
including other journalists might stand
up and say
hold on censorship is wrong censorship
only serves the powerful but they've
said nothing
because they agree meanwhile our elected
officials become
openly authoritarian and no one pushes
back
dc mayor muriel bowser said she would
like the national guard to place
crew-served machine guns belt-fed 50
cals
around the city this in addition to 26
000 federal troops more than abraham
lincoln had defending the capital in
1864.
but we need those she said because trump
voters are that dangerous
what did the massive infrastructure of
professional libertarians in washington
say to this
nothing they were silent what did mitch
mcconnell say
the republican leader of the senate
nothing
he was too busy attacking trump voters
for being the real threat
other members of congress on the other
side just tore off the mass completely
and launched into open race hate on
television that's not an exaggeration we
wish it was
here's congressman jamal bowman
explaining that the real problem with
this country is white people
they're the threat to progress but this
is a chance for all of us in congress
to sort of begin at a new baseline and
stop
spreading the myth of american
exceptionalism
and accept the fact that this is exactly
who we are
and this is exactly who we've been
throughout our country's history
whenever there's social progress there's
white backlash
the story here is not that one member of
congress said this on television the
story
is that many members of congress and
members of our media say this on
television
every single day attack huge groups
of americans on the basis of their skin
color and nobody says anything
nobody pushes back as if they're no
consequences
to talking that way but there are
how long can people keep talking like
that and keep acting like this
irresponsibly
crazily before something breaks before
one of those 74 million hunted terrorist
trotskyite wreckers we keep hearing
about
becomes so overwrought and paranoid from
watching demagogues like jamal bowman
attack him on msnbc that he does
something truly awful
that can't be taken back and then the
cycle accelerates
radically and an awful lot of people get
hurt
that's where this is going everyone
knows it that's where this will go
until and unless someone responsible
within the democratic party appears and
puts a stop to it and
soon it's time for the victors to accept
their victory
to forgive the team they beat and to
move on
you won be happy now improve the country
you inherited